in southern Pennsylvania there is a
battlefield a battlefield so important
that it is thought to be the turning
point of the American Civil War this is
a story about that place it's also a
story about cats thousands and thousands
of little cats this is Rebecca
hi I'm Rebecca and this is her twin
sister Ruth hi I'm Ruth and we run a
museum of dioramas that are made with a
handmade Civil War cats Civil War cats
the combination of a childhood love for
clay cats and a strong fascination with
the American Civil War it started out as
a hobby that we just did as kids putzing
around in our bedrooms that bit of
child's play led to a full fledged
museum which opened in 2013
the two of us discussed how much do we
want to emphasize the cat thing because
we don't want to come off as cutesy cats
the idea is the stories of the men not
so much the fact that they're cats they
just are cats because they're cats
incredibly each of these scenes is to
scale 1/8 of an inch equals one foot in
cat feet and so each one of our soldiers
represents one soldier who would have
been on the field will calculate the
numbers that would have been left in the
regiment and we'll fill it in with that
many cat soldiers so for example lower
on top we're going to eventually have
about 5,000 soldiers on it typically one
like the angle we figure took us about
four and a half years the Little Round
Top diorama we figures more of a five or
six year diorama look we really just
want to make the Civil War more
approachable I guess for people so they
can relate to the history and have more
of a connection with the men and the
women involved now that the word of this
cat museums out all the people who love
cats come in and now not only are they
seeing our dioramas of falling in love
with the five and a half thousand little
furry smiles smiling at them but they're
also learning the stories and suddenly
they have an appreciation of Gettysburg
and the history just because they came
to see the cats
[Music]
you